>> Bret: WE WILL UNPACK ALL OF
THAT ON THE PANEL.
THANK YOU.
WE ARE WAITING TO INFORMATION
ABOUT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL FROM
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL ABOUT A
FEDERAL INTERVIEW WITH OUT A
LAWYER PRESENT, A KEY FIGURE IN
THE RUSH OF COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE FILLS US IN.
>> FILED LATE WEDNESDAY NIGHT,
THE ORDER FOR MIKE FROM FEDERAL
JUDGE GIVES AUBERT MULLER'S TEAM
LESS THAN 48 HOURS TO PROVIDE ON
RECORD THAT UNDERLYING NOTES AND
THE FBI'S JANUARY 2017 INTERVIEW
A FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR MIKE FLYNN IN THE
WHITE HOUSE SITUATION ROOM.
IN COURT PAPERS THIS WEEK, HIS
ATTORNEY CLAIMS THAT FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE FIRED
FOR LYING TO FEDERAL
INVESTIGATORS OVER MEDIA LEAKS,
CALLED HIM ON SHORT NOTICE AND
THEN SENT TWO AGENTS INCLUDING
PETER STRZOK WHO SENT TRUMP TAX
TO THE INTERVIEW.
THE FILING ALSO CLAIMS THAT HE
DISCOURAGED HIM FROM HAVING A
LAWYER PRESENCE.
BY CONTRAST, HIS LEGAL TEAM SET
OTHER WITNESSES WERE WARNED OF
THE PROBES THE SERIOUS NATURE.
OVER THE WEEKEND, HE SAID HE WAS
DIRECTLY INVOLVED.
HE BELIEVED FLYNN'S STATEMENTS
ABOUT HIS RUSSIA CONTACT WITH
THE VICE PRESIDENT CONFLICTED
WITH FBI EVIDENCE.
>> I SENT THEM.
SOMETHING I PROBABLY WOULDN'T
HAVE DONE OR GOTTEN AWAY WITH IN
A MORE ORGANIZED INVESTIGATION.
A MORE ORGANIZED ADMINISTRATION.
IN THE GEORGE BUSCH
ADMINISTRATION OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
>> LESTER LITTLE REPUBLICAN
HOUSE INVESTIGATORS THAT THE FBI
AGENTS REPORTED NO SIGNS OF
DECEPTION FROM THE FLYNN
INTERVIEW.
DESPITE THE GUILTY PLEA, THE
PRESIDENT COMMENTED ON HIM TOLD
FOX HE BELIEVES THE FORMER AIDE
WAS PRESSURED.
>> THEY CONVINCED HIM HE DID
LIFE AND HE MAKE SOME KIND OF A
DEAL.
NOW THEY ARE RECOMMENDING NO
TIME.
YOU KNOW WHY?
THEY ARE EMBARRASSED.
>> SULLIVAN HAS A TRACK RECORD
FOR CALLING OUT PROSECUTOR MAKES
CONTACT COMMAS ORDER PUTS THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL TEAM ON A TIGHT
TIMELINE, THE SENTENCING IS
SENTENCED FOR TUESDAY.
>> Bret: AND OTHER
DEVELOPMENT, THE ALLEGED RUSSIAN
SPY, SHE ENTERED THE GUILTY PLEA
TO CONSPIRACY CHARGES TODAY.
WE FOUND OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> SHE PLED GUILTY TO ONE CHARGE
OF CONSPIRACY TO ACT AS AN AGENT
TO A FOREIGN COUNTRY, SHE
UNDERSTOOD THE NATURE OF THE
CHARGE AGAINST HER.
SHE WAS ACTING UP HER OWN FREE
WILL WHEN SHE ENTERED THE PLEA.
PROSECUTORS PLAN THAT SHE DID
HER CONTACTS WITH THE RIFLE
ASSOCIATION TO DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS WITH POLITICIANS
AND GATHER INTELLIGENCE FOR